okay here we are
Rachel will the Democrats be able to
take back the Senate in 2020 what's your
prediction on that the Senate cuz if we
don't get this anything that's all kind
of moving so now that the socialist
prospect has been vanquished and the
party will not be running against itself
which is a really critical element yes
the Colorado and Maine are definitely
flipping as will Arizona so the question
is which ones are lutely
Colorado in Arizona okay so when my
forecast for the house and the Senate
come out we'll be talking about at least
six House seats in addition to the ones
they gained in 2018 but that's because
they didn't understand in this new
environment where to spend money it's in
these realigning suburbs which are by
the way realigning because of the
millennial generation who are now 40
they're balding they don't houses right
not college kids
sitting on their ass not voting before
but now they're freaked out okay and so
when we look at the suburban revolution
it's not a Republican women singing
Kumbaya and having like buyer's remorse
in fact if you look at my analyses which
I really urge you guys to do anyone
who's hearing this please do you're
gonna see Republicans are stoked on
Donald Trump they love what this man is
doing they're not disaffected they
showed up they increase their turnout in
2018 and Democrats are actually flipping
seats because of independents and
Democrats who are changing the
composition electorate they're making it
less white younger more female and
better educated and that's what saving
America
someone raised with Britain's National
Health Service why do you think some
Americans are so hesitant to embrace
Medicare for all I have no idea I mean I
think you know and the National Health
Service is phenomenal at you know and
well and each go sub well you know each
government tries to screw it up by in
palling appalling middle management and
it's a middle management that's done the
job not the people on the ground not the
nurses not the doctors but the
management that's been [ __ ] but doctors
in England paid a salary right yeah okay
I mean that's gonna be a tough sell in
America well of course everybody's a
tough sell Yeah right I'm just just -
what's new in the idea of a National
Health Service you know it was started
by Clement Lee and an iron Bevin two
great politicians actly probably being
the greatest Prime Minister I think we
ever had and right after a turn he was
right after church he managed the
country of our church who was doing the
war that was the interesting thing about
him and he was very quiet it's very
quiet man but anyway I think that the
National Health Service is you know they
try to destroy it they'll try and sell
it they'll try to do everything
particularly the Tories but it still
goes on and that's great Ross is the
coronavirus the kind of event that could
force us out of our state of decadence
which of course is the subject of your
book that's a terrific question thank
you mom yeah so yes I mean it's a little
weird because I'm out promoting this
book about how we're stuck in these
loops of you know decaying institutions
and stalemated politics and the same
Star Wars movies over and over again and
I'm doing this while the coronavirus is
basically sweeping through and putting
it all to the torch so yeah I can say
definitively you know pandemics are not
decadent they're really bad but they're
definitely not decadent but it is a test
for I mean what I was talking about
earlier basically the institutional
failure at every level that we've had in
response to it that is decadence
that's what decadence looks like and and
you know I mean more than you I think
it's
it's gonna be worse than the flu I think
what's gonna be worse than the fluid the
dick coronavirus it could be we will
have what are you basing that on
you know Italy mostly Iran even even I
mean even South Korea the best
containment we've got has a fatality
rate of 0.6 and the flu is 0.1 so that's
for every person you said dies of the
flu every year which is too many you
could have six people dead which is well
hundreds of thousands of people so I
think this is debate about that I don't
think you're well that's the low end
that's yeah that's the low end the WHL
edge today that it's the people most in
to worry about this of course our over
eighty eighty number and even among
eighty it's one out of six and I still
had six to one odds worst when you're 80
I mean I mean we have death you know
part of decadence I think is that people
we you're right it's always about victim
of your own success I mean you think of
the the French you know kings and at the
time of Louis the 14th I mean everything
was just so so a feat and nothing they
could they could they couldn't stand any
sort of pain they sat on thousands of
pillows that's where we are now
yeah people sitting on thousands of
pillows absolutely right pandemic so I
mean yes Amex are worse than that they
are but it's not the can't you can't yes
routing it forward I'm not let me be
clear I am against
[Applause]
also on the campaign okay well what does
the coronavirus do to the campaign Trump
is so screwed right because it's gonna
totally the economy everybody says that
everything that happens and he's never
definitely definitely not helped no I
said you can see I did his talk right he
had all of these rich people who were
able to say well I've got my
conservative judges who will one day
redefine American citizenship so our
minority population can hold on to power
and I have money right from the stock
market well my parents are living off of
retirement funds they lost like 40% of
their stock
yeah you said his mouth lost two
trillion dollars 100 justjust what he
said a hundred percent that more stress
of what it would have been okay look I'm
a clear eyed money manager running 11s
you are I want you like money
I want you had a lot of watch that guy's
press compromised I said okay
the market is gonna sell off on this be
sure it's science you want to say that
the Trump Tower condominium is 10,000
square feet one 1,000 problem okay
hit the science right bullseye yeah that
cost and then he opened his mouth on
Sean Hannity's show and and that costs
another trillion in research like
economy right people are ghetto Trump's
in this great position because the
economy is strong [ __ ] right in the
old days the economy mattered so Carvel
was right one time but not anymore right
but the a bad economy on a guy that
everyone hates just reporter how that
went for her not everyone not everyone
in America hates a little bubble it's
about forty it's about forty three
percent and he's gonna get about forty
seven percent so the question will be
can the Trump team make enough not Trump
voters vote against their own intricate
right
certainly you've made my point not
everyone what are your thoughts panel on
Bill Clinton saying in the new
documentary I guess this came out today
that his affair with Monica Lewinsky was
a way of quote managing my anxieties and
lets you know about this is addressed to
you but I put it to the whole Sue is
taken out of context it did seem to
readdress his anxieties he did very well
I know it's a president right now you
know sounds right to me does help your
anxiety back to the Bloomberg [ __ ]
turmoil I just think it would be they
would be better served as Democrats to
stay out of the way right now why
surfers that and bring up the fact that
he was impeached and all that other
stuff it just colors bad Clinton's never
miss an opportunity missed an
opportunity to eat mom right Democrats
like I just gotta say no symmetry of him
getting impeached and plus it yes
tonight for one second channel Monica
Lewinsky and I don't think Monica likes
me very much
yeah I you know may have done a few
jokes in the past
I tried to when she came out a few years
ago and Vanity Fair and wrote that I
kind of I tried to defend her and then I
saw and she was like your defense was
not good enough or it was the wrong kind
of defense as I know you're dead to her
yeah but I just gotta say that the
blindness of a man saying that I had
this affair with this person it was to
manage my anxieties how does that make
her feel it's like it's just a just a
terrible thing to say it you don't
reminds me of that's when people are
with like their second wife and they
just go on it this is the love of my
life and I didn't live before I met it
was the first wife and the Clintons are
very blind to that the come on they have
a callousness they really do this to me
was very callous it's like manage my
anxieties you know really there was not
a human being there she's revealed that
she was in love with him and she opened
up about what she felt about it and then
and he might and that was more than just
managing Minds as I recall that he
bought her that book of poetry it was
like and there was that tape where he
was like good morning cuz he got a
[ __ ] that day and like you know he
was a little more than that all right
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you